dans l'actualité ce soir un puissant
tremblement de terre a fait au moins
huit mille 700 morts dans le sud de la
chine des milliers d'immeubles des
universités des lycées des usines se
sont effondrées sur leurs occupants
l'armée nationale est mobilisée george
bush propose l'aide des états unis
la birmanie ouvre un peu plus ses portes
à l'aide humanitaire après la
croix-rouge l'onu et la grèce ce sont
les états unis et la france qui ont pu
envoyer un avion sur place plein de
matériel
en france les réactions sont réservées
après l'annnonce de jean louis borloo
sur france 2 dès éthylotests devront
être installés dans tous les bars et les
boîtes de nuit
on verra comment fonctionnent ces
machines après la logan renault nissan
se lance dans la fabrication d'une
nouvelle voiture à très bas coût 1600
euros
elle sera réalisée pour le marché indien
en coproduction avec un groupe local
accident ou bavures un jeune homme de 22
ans est mort à grasse ce week end après
son interpellation des témoins accusent
la police évoque un trop fortement
violent enfin à l'occasion de la
pentecôte et de son pèlerinage notre
enquête sur l'ouverture des frontières
aux prêtres étrangers
ils sont plus de 1000 leur nombre a
doublé en cinq ans pour compenser la
baisse des vocations
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous un désastre
chasse l'autre en asie après le cyclone
en birmanie c'est la chine qui a donc
été frappée par un violent séisme
7 8 sur l'échelle de richter il a été
ressenti presque partout dans le pays
un bilan très lourd est à craindre car
les secours commencent à peine à évaluer
les dégâts jérôme wierre matrix en
brasse
il est 14 heures 28 en chine et la terre
tremble caché sous une table un étudiant
filmée par un camarade moment d'effroi
saisi par un téléphone portable ou ici
on par une caméra de vidéosurveillance
presque trois minutes d'une secousse
surpuissante 7,8 sur l'échelle de
richter
elle a été ressentie à des milliers de
kilomètres l'évacuation commence à toute
vitesse ils sont rapidement des dizaines
de milliers sur les trottoirs inquiet
river au téléphone mais les
communications passent très mal
évacuation aussi des hôpitaux beaucoup
plus compliqué cette femme raconte à la
maternité chacun prenait un bébé pour le
sortir de l'hôpital parfois des parents
se tromper ne prenaient pas leurs
enfants
nous sommes à chengdu première grande
ville à moins de 100 km de l'épicentre
dix millions d'habitants dont 200
français est vraiment les immeubles et
grossit neuf sont fissurés par endroits
à l'extérieur donc ça a été tout de même
où se trouve cette fois pour tenter
beaucoup de la nuit est en effet tombé
en chine et on commence à peine à
mesurer l'ampleur des dégâts
là dans un district près de l'épicentre
on dit que huit maisons sur dix sont
détruites mais des villes entières n'ont
pas encore été atteinte par les sous qui
la zone montagneuse est inaccessible
les routes sont recouvertes de pierres
de nombreuses écoles des hôpitaux se
sont effondrés comme des châteaux de
cartes
dans la ville de douz les secouristes
ont engagé une course contre la montre
ils doivent extraire 900 jeunes prises
au piège dans les décombres de leur
lycée au moins cinquante d'entre eux
sont déjà morts
ce soir le premier ministre wen jiabao
est arrivé sur place il a clairement
évoqué un désastre
il annonce la mobilisation de l'armée un
déploiement de force abondamment filmé
par la télévision d'état huit mille sept
cents morts pour l'instant bonsoir samah
soula vous êtes en direct à pékin
là bas on s'attend un bilan de beaucoup
plus grande ampleur oui ce bilan
d'environ 9000 morts et hélas provisoire
il faut savoir que l'épicentre du séisme
qui se trouve en bordure du plateau du
tibet n'a pas encore été atteint c'est
une région très montagneuse et les
routes sont ensevelis sous les roches
effondré autour de l'épicentre à
situation est dramatique des écoles des
hôpitaux des usines des bâtiments se
sont effondrés c'est une course contre
la montre qui a commencé pour les
secours pour tenter de sauver des
survivants avec un facteur aggravant de
fortes pluies annoncées pour les trois
prochains jours
ce qui retient l'attention aussi sa main
c'est que le pouvoir chinois s'est
exprimé assez vite il semble décidé à
jouer la transparence
oui et c'est une première en tout cas il
a apporté une réponse très rapide en
annonçant l'envoi immédiat de l'armée
sur place et - près d'une heure trente
seulement après le tremblement de terre
le premier ministre est apparu à la
télévision pour dire que tout serait
fait pour porter secours aux victimes et
surtout qu'il allait se rendre sur place
c'est tout à fait inhabituel pour le
régime chinois dans la gestion de ces
crises même les pires catastrophes
précédentes et puis vous avez des images
de cette catastrophe
les chinois ne sont pas habitués à ce
genre de traitement en tout cas immédiat
médiatiquement par la dernière chose ça
m'a on pense évidemment aux jeux
olympiques est ce que les autorités
chinoises y ont fait allusion
alors très rapidement un communiqué
officiel a indiqué que les
infrastructures olympiques n'étaient pas
touchés et même si les jeux olympiques
apparaissent comme dérisoire comparé au
milieu des eaux nombre aux milliers de
victimes
évidemment les jeux olympiques sont au
coeur de la gestion de cette crise les
autorités chinoises savent qu'elles
n'ont pas le droit à l'erreur et que
toute assimilation à la gestion de ce
tremblement de terre à la désastreuse
gestion en birmanie serait tout à fait
déplorable pour la chine
merci samah soula pour tous ces éléments
alors ça n'est pas la première fois que
la chine est frappée par un violent
séisme
on sait que la zone est très sensible
d'un point de vue sismique que s'est il
passé
explication patrice pelé jean-pierre
pasteur les indiens sont loin de se
douter que c'est leur pays l'inde qui
est à l'origine du tremblement de terre
d'aujourd'hui
en effet depuis 50 millions d'années
l'inde s'encastre vers le nord
c'est d'abord l'himalaya qui reçoit une
poussée de cinq centimètres par an puis
ensuite l'immense plateau du tibet qui
prend le relais et qui va à son tour
bousculé la chine une telle faille est
extrêmement importante et car elle est
en fait associé avec un déplacement ou
une rupture si vous préférez de
plusieurs mètres
donc c'est quelque chose qui s'est
traduit par un six majeur comme il n'en
existe heureusement opus 1 à 2 par la
chine tout entière et donc habitués aux
séismes
celui de 76 dans le gansu avait fait
deux cent mille morts
celui d'aujourd'hui qui dépasse 7 5 sur
l'échelle de richter va maintenant sa
compagne et deux répliques probablement
très forte plus le csdhi principal va
être important plus les répliques
également vont être importantes
magnitude 7 points 8 cela veut dire
qu'il y aura dix répliques qui vont
dépasser
dominique six la carte des tremblements
de terre montre bien qu'aucune région
chinoise est épargné pas même le nord
verte etc
alors faut-il craindre d'éventuelles
secousses pendant les jeux olympiques
aucun scientifique sérieux ne peut
répondre à cette question ce soir
dernière précision le barrage géant des
trois gorges sur le fleuve yangtsé et
dans le centre du pays n'aurait pas
souffert même s'il séisme a été ressenti
dans la région
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire ce soir nous
y revenons bien sûr dans le courant de
ce journal
en cas de nouvelles informations la
birmanie de son côté ouvre un peu plus
les portes à l'aide humanitaire après la
croix-rouge l'onu et la grèce ce sont
les états unis qui ont pu envoyer un
avion sur place un autre appareil
français a décollé de l'aéroport de
vatry dans la marne philippe rochot
c'est un événement humanitaire mais
aussi diplomatiques les américains ont
réussi à poser leur premier avion dead à
la birmanie dix jours après le passage
dévastateur du cyclone
la junte a finalement cédé et entrouvre
les portes du pays 12 tonnes de
nourriture de l'eau des couvertures dans
la foulée un avion français avec du
matériel de la croix rouge est attendu
demain et le navire français le mistral
pourrait arriver jeudi avec 1500 tonnes
de riz à mesure que l'aide arrive on
découvre l'ampleur du cyclone qui a
balayé le delta beau gala y est la ville
la plus touchée
ici vivaient 350 mille habitants dix
villes sont morts comme les enfants de
cette école et 200000 sont affectées par
la catastrophe
je suis resté bloqué dans mon village
pendant cinq jours sans nourriture et
sans eau
je viens seulement du jus de noix de
coco sont des moines qui la junte
militaire transforme l'aide
internationale en opération de
propagande et s'affiche en sauveur des
victimes du cyclone
mais le pays n'a reçu que 160 tonnes d
aide alimentaire
il en faudrait dix fois plus en france
les réactions sont mitigées après
l'annnonce de jean louis borloo et hier
soir ici même à propos de sécurité
routière vous le savez des éthylotests
électroniques devront être installés
dans tous les bars et les boîtes de nuit
pour inciter les conducteurs à évaluer
leur taux d'alcoolémie certains
établissements en sont déjà équipés
jean-françois fier et frédéric basket ce
n'est plus un ballon mais une borne
électronique
le principe lui est le même on souffle
et la machine mesure le taux d'alcool
par litre d'air expiré négatif
l'éthylotest indique l'alcoolémie exact
au dessus de 0,5 g
le pde positif s'affiche cette
discothèque lilloise tests déjà
l'éthylotest électronique viser en
priorité les conducteurs les plus jeunes
c'est une utilité voire même une
obligation par simon en vente d'alcool
d'informer les gens sur leur capacité ou
non de reprendre le volant après le
gérant de ce bar parisien craint lui de
devenir un policier comment faire
respecter la mesure à des gens qui ne le
souhaitent pas c'est quasiment
impossible à faire appliquer à quelqu un
d de lui demander de sucre et après
avoir bu une bouteille de vin
d'autant qu'il va nous dire on et off
dans les grandes agglomérations comme
paris il va nous dire qu'il a pas qu'il
est venu en métro en toute façon de
remettre un appareil sert absolument à
rien regarde l'empêchent de picoler de
souffler dedans et puis de monter dans
sa bagnole et comptines coup de la bande
2500 euros que les cafetiers devront
assumer seul d'accord répond des
syndicats mais avec une aide financière
de l'état
attention aussi à ne pas se tromper de
cible quelque part parce qu'il ya
beaucoup plus de choses que l'alcool
était acheté ailleurs que chez nous en
tout cas hors de toute réglementation
les associations d'usagers de la route
salué un premier pas les réclament des
mesures plus dissuasives
l'éthylotest électronique concernera 45
mille établissements entrée en vigueur
en janvier 2009 après avis du conseil
d'état et on s'y attendait ce soir
retour de week end oblige les principaux
axes autour des grandes villes sont très
encombrés images ici de montpellier et
de lyon bison futé avait prévu des
embouteillages
il a fallu effectivement se montrer
patient ça risque de durer une bonne
partie de la soirée encore on reste dans
le domaine de l'automobile
après la logan renault nissan se lance
donc dans la fabrication d'une nouvelle
voiture à très bas coût 1600 euros elle
sera réalisée en coproduction avec un
groupe indien
officiellement seuls le marché local
sera concerné
souvenons nous tout de même qu on disait
la même chose de la logan fabriquée en
roumanie est désormais vendu aussi en
france cyril za fabrice launay
sous les flashs il ya quelques mois
l'indien ratan tata avait tracé la route
avec sa nano à 1600 euros
la voiture la moins chère du monde un
véhicule minimale accessible au plus
grand nombre sans cesse adapter aux
besoins de la circulation en inde l'un
des berceaux de la voiture à bas coût
déjà l'an passé le patron de renault
nissan lui avait emprunté cette nouvelle
voie pour sa logan construite sur place
et commercialiser avec mahindra autre
groupe automobile indien
effectivement la dette un marché qui est
très très compétitif et la main d'oeuvre
indienne et d'une très très grande
qualité de la nouvelle alliance de
renault avec bajaj spécialiste du deux
roues et des triporteurs devrait donc
n'être lui elle ses 2500 $ 1620 euros
une nouvelle voiture à bas coût dont le
groupe indien avait présenté une ébauche
en janvier dernier depuis ce matin c'est
officiel les deux constructeurs se sont
engagés à lancer le projet ils n'ont pas
encore arrêté les caractéristiques du
véhicule
objectif d'ebit 2011 produire en 1 400
mille unités par an à cette date la nano
concurrents du groupe tata conçu à
l'origine pour le marché indien se
vendra en europe l'économie nicolas
sarkozy reprend demain son bâton de
pèlerin pour défendre le projet de loi
visant à augmenter la concurrence entre
grandes surfaces et donc à tenter de
limiter la hausse des prix une
disposition assouplie notamment les
règles d'implantation de ces grandes
surfaces
c'est un changement de cap depuis quinze
ou vingt ans cherchait au contraire à
limiter leur nombre pour épargner le
petit commerce mais ces lois sont
aujourd'hui contestées valérie le rouge
une petite révolution il ya tout juste
50 ans
les premiers magasins en libre service
apparaissent les rayons s'allongent et
les clients découvrent les chariots les
consommateurs prennent vite leur
habitude les commerçants traditionnels
le grincent des dents
début des années 70 il se mobilise
autour du syndicat cidunati contre ce
qu'ils appellent les croque mitaine du
commerce moderne équilibre doit exister
au niveau de l'urbanisme
le ministre du commerce de l'époque les
enfances la loi jean royer est votée en
1973 et instaure une autorisation
préalable pour tous magasins de plus de
1000 mètres qu'à une règle qui ne freine
pas la multiplication des gros
hypermarchés dans les années 90
nouvelles donnes les hard discounters
allemands débarquent avec des magasins
inférieur à 1000 mètres carrés ils n'ont
pas besoin d'autorisation et inquiète
les enseignes françaises
en 1996 le ministre des pme vient donc à
leur rescousse
jean pierre raffarin durci la loi royer
toutes grandes surfaces non plus de 1000
mhz et 2 300 m² devra obtenir le
précieux sésame
conséquence les ouvertures de super et
hypermarchés sont en chute libre de plus
de 400 par an elles sont aujourd'hui à
moins de 80 malgré ces deux lois le
commerce de centre-ville n'a pas été
épargné et certains grands distributeurs
détiennent de véritable monopole pour
accroître la concurrence et faire
baisser les prix une troisième loi
propose donc aujourd'hui de revenir aux
seules initiales des mille mètres carrés
et de réformer le fonctionnement des
commissions chargées de donner leur
accord
que s'est il passé exactement à grasse
vendredi dernier un jeune homme de 22
ans est mort peu après une
interpellation mouvementée
ils avaient été arrêtés après une
altercation dans une banque des témoins
accusent la préfecture elle des
alpes-maritimes évoque un comportement
violent elle rappelle aussi que deux
policiers ont été eux-mêmes blessée la
victime avait fait plusieurs séjours en
hôpital psychiatrique sur place vincent
capus nils brunelli la famille d'hakim a
souhaité nous montrer la dizaine de
témoignages qui lui est parvenue de
personnes présentes lors de
l'interpellation qui a tourné au drame
vendredi
un système où logent des gens qui sont
venus spontanément avec l'herpès
d'endetter elle est monnayage parmi ces
témoignages celui de ludovic il a
assisté à la scène et a même tenté de
s'interposer
la personne était
maîtrisé par terre l'autre policier qui
prenait son visage comme ça et le
tourner jusqu'à de l'autre côté et
l'autre le deuxième policier par contre
était sur la personne qui était allongé
donc le tir et le corps vers le haut et
l'autre personne avec le genou une
pression vers la colonne vers le bas
donc la personne n'arrivait plus à
respirer était plus les mêmes pas rouge
violette vendredi hakim se rend à sa
banque pour retirer de l'argent il n'y
arrive pas ce qui le plonge dans une
colère noire il gifle alors le directeur
de l' agence son interpellation se passe
mal le jeune homme est très énervé deux
fonctionnaires sont blessés embarquez
hakim décédera quelques minutes plus
tard ce que monsieur ajimi a été amené
dans la voiture de police
ou en tout cas sur les lieux il était
conscient et on n'avait pas en tout cas
l'impression qu'ils nécessitaient
immédiatement des soins sur place
l'igpn a été saisie de l'enquêté selon
la préfecture aucun élément ne permet
pour l'instant de mettre en cause
l'action de la police hier à grasse un
millier de personnes a manifesté pour
dénoncer une bavure le corps d'hakim
sera autopsié demain la santé publique
avec un rendez vous très attendu dans
les prochains jours c'est cette semaine
que le gouvernement annonce son plan
contre l'autisme et nous vous proposons
un document qui donne de l'espoir oui il
y a des solutions oui il ya des
améliorations possibles et parfois
spectaculaires vous allez le voir pour
les malades l'une de nos équipes a suivi
à plusieurs années d'intervalle
l'évolution d'un enfant il a bénéficié
d'un suivi et d'une attention permanente
un investissement important mais qui
porte ses fruits
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé laetitia legendre vincent
bouffartigue attentif concentré
edouard lèvent le doigt
rêvons aux questions du professeur le
fruit d'années de travail de patience
car le petit garçon est autiste
ces progrès ce sont ses copains d'école
qui en parle
il ya quelques années c'est un enfant
qui ne nous regardait pas il passe à
côté nous son regard ne s'arrêtait
passion aujourd'hui son regard et
weitbruch garder le matin il y a cinq
ans son intégration dans la classe n'a
pas été simple crise de colère accès de
violence l'équipe pédagogique à jouer le
jeu
quand nous l'avions rencontré il ya deux
ans et demi edward se lever encore un
peu avait du mal parfois à se concentrer
aujourd'hui il sait lire compter grâce à
une étudiante en psychologie qui
l'accompagnent en permanence et le
récompense quand il réussit son activité
une friandise ou un peu de musique
ce qu'il préfère que notre but c'est
nous retirer
mesure donc là c'est vraiment on les
cadre le temps de diminuer les
comportements qui leur faut ce point est
un mec qui leur permettent pas d'être
dans l'école normalement et après à la
cantine est moche
mais l'après midi edwards est encadrée
dans un centre spécialisé par des
étudiants en psychologie bénévoles on y
expérimentent un traitement
la méthode dite aebea controversée en
france mais largement reconnue à
l'étranger
elle demande des moyens financiers et
humains importants
un enfant quelle décennie ça coûte cher
quoi une personne nous présente sous
cette forme là pour des en fonction des
handicaps de ce type là m'ont dit ça
coûte cher
une méthode une attention permanente que
la merde edwards a dû apprendre elle
aussi elle a revu toute son éducation
avec l'aide de la psychologue du petit
garçon ouais trop bien est plus chère
balle elle le cadre le félicite car les
progrès sont là edwards a 3 ans ne
parlait pas se taper la tête contre les
murs dormait à peine désormais le petit
garçon cuisine avec sa mère sort au
restaurant sans problème on peut
l'emmener partout dans un magasin alors
qu'avant c'était très difficile
il partait en courant on le perdait
pendant quelques minutes puis on le
retrouvait en train de sauter devant des
bouteilles d'eau aujourd'hui fait les
courses avec nous donc ça c'est en cours
d'acquisition j'ai tiré il est en train
de sortir de sa bulle et c'est le plus
beau cadeau c'est on va peut-être
réussir à lui apprendre un petit métier
on va aller vers une de plus en plus
d'autonomie et puis en plus il connaît
toute sa famille il nous connaît il nous
aime
il nous apporte daf et de l'affection
s'il vous plaît edwards edwards était un
étranger pour nous à l'époque
maintenance et voilà quoi petit à petit
au il rentre dans notre monde parce que
rentrer dans le sien je sais pas si
c'est la solution
cette méthode suscite de nombreux
espoirs chez les parents d'enfants
outils le centre expérimental qui suit
edouard vient de recevoir un agrément
pour deux ans il a déjà permis à la mère
des douars de découvrir son fils
autrement et de profiter de ces moments
des changes si précieux l'immigration
pardonnez moi est un sujet important en
france sa maîtrise est devenue un thème
central du nouveau gouvernement italien
de silvio berlusconi elle est au centre
de la première réforme qui a été annoncé
aujourd'hui par le ministre de
l'intérieur roberto maroni membre de la
ligue du nord le texte prévoit un
refoulement systématique en haute mer
des embarcations transportant des
clandestins vers l'italie ou encore un
durcissement des règles en vigueur
contre les roumains et notamment les
tziganes pour faciliter leur expulsion
en cas de troubles il faut savoir que la
ligue du nord principal allié de silvio
berlusconi a bâti son succès électoral
précisément sur ce sujet à rome philippe
visseyrias clara bosco giancarlo
giannini n'a pas le triomphe modeste
devant ses militants combler dans ce
petit village de vénétie le tribun de la
ligue du nord cultive son goût pour la
provocation de la ligue je veux libérer
nos rues de ces étrangers clandestins
au nord je ne veux pas de mosquée
détruisons les villes la ligue
autour de lui des fils quelques-uns des
60 députés des 25 sénateurs de la ligue
tel look at zahia qui sera ministre de
l'agriculture du nouveau gouvernement
berlusconi pour un fichage adn de tous
les immigrés qui vivent en italie la
ligue du nord un parti xénophobe au
coeur du pouvoir dans cette veine et si
rural et prospère où règne encore le
plein emploi la ligue attire 30 % des
électeurs et cristallisent les fleurs
des habitants les grandes villes du nord
ont également succombé au discours
sécuritaire vérone deux cent soixante
mille habitants dont trente mille
étrangers et la nouvelle vitrine de la
ligue du nord ces arènes romaines le
balcon de roméo et juliette et son maire
de 38 ans élu l'an dernier avec 61% des
vhu flavio tosi est fier de montrer
l'une de ses réalisations la destruction
d'un camp qui accueillait des digues and
roam ces tas de pierres on ne les a pas
laissés par hasard c'est pour rendre ces
terrains impraticables pour ne pas qu'il
revienne à vérone les gens qui ne
veulent pas s'intégrer ne sont pas
refermées les frontières expulser les
clandestins
l'obsession d'uberto booth diminué par
un accident cardio vasculaire
le leader historique de la ligue du nord
entend encore peser sur son allié silvio
berlusconi
les deux hommes se connaissent bien de
2001 à 2006 umberto bossi a déjà fait
partie du gouvernement de silvio
berlusconi mais cette fois ci la ligue
du nord a doublé son poids électoral et
compte bien imposer ses vues en matière
d'immigration au sein du nouveau
gouvernement à l'étranger en corée en
bref la victoire du parti pro-européen
aux élections législatives en serbie la
formation du président tadic ch devra
toutefois nouer des alliances pour
gouverner
en grande bretagne le premier ministre
gordon brown s'apprête à annoncer de
nouvelles mesures pour donner un
deuxième souffle au système de santé
là-bas la logique de la banalisation des
soins a été poussé très loin
certaines grandes surfaces proposent
désormais les services d'un médecin
installé au milieu des rayons à
manchester maryse burgot laurent des
bois
entre le rayon boucherie et le rayon
couches-culottes un cabinet médical
nous sommes bel et bien dans un
supermarché deux soirs par semaine ce
médecin généraliste de secteur public
qui son cabinet en ville pour donner ici
des consultations c'est surtout il
destiné aux personnes qui travaillent
mais aussi à ceux qui ont des enfants et
qui ne peuvent s'absenter la journée
pour aller voir leur docteur c'est
certes pratique mais faute de salles
d'attentes les patients sont au beau
milieu des caddies et des clients c'est
vrai que c'est un peu exposés
c'est pas vraiment intime nous sommes
bien loin des promesses de ce ministre
qui lançait en 1948 le fameux nhs le
système de santé britannique nhs
comptera désormais des médecins de
famille qui viendront chez vous à
domicile si nécessaire soixante ans plus
tard les britanniques patiente encore
listes d'attentes pour se faire opérer
dans le public files d'attentes pour
s'inscrire chez un dentiste conventionné
après les coupes budgétaires des années
satcher le nhs est toujours convalescent
et les patients qui en ont les moyens se
tournent de plus en plus vers le privé
peut-être que cela va permettre de
réduire les listes d'attentes pour
obtenir un rendez-vous dans le secteur
public
et puis c'est vraiment pratique de se
faire soigner tout en faisant ses
courses en encourageant ce concept de
médecins de supermarchés le gouvernement
britannique espère réconcilier ses
concitoyens avec le nez chess mais cette
initiative ne fait pas vraiment
l'unanimité l'ordre britanniques des
médecins jeu
aujourd'hui indécent que l'on puisse
consulter son docteur quasiment au
milieu des fruits des légumes mais aussi
des bouteilles d'alcool ou des
cigarettes en france le traditionnel
pèlerinage de la pentecôte près de 8000
personnes ont participé aux trois jours
de marche qui les ont conduits à la
cathédrale notre dame de chartres
c'est un temps fort dans l'année pour
l'église catholique l'église qui est
toujours confronté à la baisse des
vocations en clair il y a de moins en
moins de prêtres et bien voilà un
domaine où l'immigration choisie est à
l'oeuvre et dans le consensus
le nombre de prêtres étrangers appelés à
la rescousse a doublé en cinq ans on en
compte plus d'un millier aujourd'hui en
france reportage dans le vaucluse
aurélia bros david dame aidé à attirer
de nouveaux fidèles dans un pays où les
églises sont de moins en moins
fréquentées c'est aussi la mission du
père apollinaire apollinaire en année
n'a à quitter sa paroisse du cameroun il
y a quatre en apportant avec lui un
style inhabituel
parce que jésus a été baptisé à voilà
avec quoi
avec 20 arrêts vélo voilà nous
l'émotion ces ingrédients favoris ils
profitent des occasions de fait comme ce
baptême pour rendre la pratique
religieuse plus dynamique
les membres
demandé qu'on prenne les bonnes au
contraire on est contents ils ont déjà
accepté la manière de faire déjà de les
battre ils sont sont contents mais
maintenant faut aller le summum passer à
une autre vitesse
le père apollinaire n'est pas le curé
d'un seul clocher comme beaucoup
d'autres prêtres il s'occupe de
plusieurs paroisses ce dimanche il prend
la route pour l'une des plus isolés de
travail si vous avez les obsèques de
deux villages se partage
c'est pas toujours facile c'est pas
toujours évident le prêtre envie que les
laïcs à s'investir dans la vie de
l'église
parce qu'à l'image des fidèles le clergé
de français vieillissant 12 prêtres
disparaissent un seul les remplacent les
prêtres étrangers viennent alors à la
rescousse
on ne doit plus de prêtres européenne
bon allez pâte et régime et non comme un
désignera les airbags chez eux c'est des
français qui ont conçu les grises au
cameroun il on se met entre récolte la
récolte grandi l'épiscopat constate
qu'en cinq ans le nombre de prêtres
étrangers a doublé cette présence
étrangère risque d'autres d'augmenter
sans devenir majoritaire car la région
cité qualities locales et bien à la
communauté locale et il faut continuer
de faire naître des vocations chez les
français en france le père apollinaire
avait signé un contrat de trois ans
faute de vocations locale il a renouvelé
son contrat
en bref les marins pêcheurs ne baisse
pas les bras avec toujours des actions
locales ici ou là contre le prix élevé
du gazole images des sables d'olonne où
l'accès au port de commerce et de
plaisance est resté bloqué les
plaisanciers de retour de week-end ont
dû attendre quelques heures avant de
pouvoir passer un petit rappel vous avez
jusqu'au 31 mai pour renvoyer par la
poste votre déclaration de revenus on a
beaucoup parlé récemment des niches
fiscales que le gouvernement
souhaiterait réduire ou supprimer
facile à dire mais chaque
une obéit à des objectifs bien précis
exemple le régime des monuments
historiques
les propriétaires de sites classés
bénéficient des aides fiscales pour
faciliter l'entretien et la restauration
de ce patrimoine
reportage dans le lot antoine gaveau
david bres
c'est un des plus beaux châteaux du lot
cénevières forteresse imprenable pendant
la guerre de cent ans errant par des
guerres de religion au 16e siècle
depuis la révolution il appartient à la
famille de braquilanges une jolie maison
de campagne certes mais aussi une source
constante d'investissement là vous avez
là les futurs chantiers sur lesquels on
est en train de travailler
il consisterait à reconstruire le toit
ça va représenter une enveloppe à peu
près de cinq cent cinquante mille euros
comme le château est classé au
patrimoine des monuments historiques
l'état et les collectivités locales
subventionnent en général 50 % des
travaux le reste est à la charge des
propriétaires qui peuvent quand même
déduire ces investissements de leurs
revenus un coup de pouce selon eux est
indispensable d'un côté on peut dire je
fais rien et tout ça part en ruine ou
bien je fais quelque chose
est ce que j arrive tout seul bah si oui
tant mieux pour moi si j'y arrive pas ça
me paraît légitime que l'état et les
collectivités
en contrepartie d'une ouverture au
public aide les propriétaires seulement
problème le gouvernement qui veut
supprimer certaines niches fiscales
envisage de réduire cet avantage un
manque à gagner pour les propriétaires
et avec moins d'argent
impossible à l'avenir d'entreprendre
tous les travaux assez clair que si les
enveloppes se réduisent si chacun 10
pensent 10% - qu'est-ce qu'il voulait
faire avant ben on est trop voit pas la
fin
les économies seraient alors réalisé au
détriment de la beauté du lieu et donc
des visiteurs ils sont quinze mille
chaque année à découvrir le château
l'environnement avec une expérience
étonnante en cours au canada comme
monsieur jourdain qui faisait de la
prose sans le savoir il devient possible
de produire de l'énergie sans s'en
rendre compte
ou presque tout simplement en marchant
le projet très sérieux et l'installation
sera sans doute bientôt commercialiser
explications alain de chalvron aaron
dimon sur place au laboratoire de
sciences appliquées de l'université de
vancouver on marche beaucoup sur les
tapis roulants comme des âmes soeurs qui
causeraient dans une roue pendant des
heures ne s'agit pas de faire de
l'exercice mais de tester une drôle de
machine que le cobaye humain à au genou
c'est exactement le même principe qu'une
dynamo sur une roue de vélo quand on
bouge le genou il entraîne un appareil
qui produit de l'électricité
de quoi faire marcher un gps téléphone
portable ou un système de vision
nocturne sans avoir à porter de lourdes
batteries en permanence première
question cet appareil augmente-t-il
l'effort musculaire nécessaire pour
marcher au début il faut faire un petit
effort supplémentaire
très vite on s'en rend même plus compte
ça fait bizarre quand on arrête la
pareille et que tout d'un coup on n'a
plus ce petit d'efforts à fournir la
jambe paraît toute légère deuxième
question cela vaut-il vraiment le coup
de fortes et intel bidule inesthétiques
et bruyant simplement pour recharger son
portable pour un particulier sans doute
pas mais il ya des cibles qui intéresse
déjà les industriels les soldats quand
ils patrouillent peuvent avoir jusqu'à
15 appareils utilisant des batteries
jantes et ne peut pas les recharger sur
le terrain ils ont besoin de 10 watts
environ idevice et notre invention peut
fournir entre 7 et 10 watts si on
l'utilisent sur les deux genoux
les armées américaines et canadiennes
ont déjà marqué leur intérêt et
participent aux recherches
ce sont là des centaines de milliers de
jeunes ou en perspective un vrai jackpot
un mot de football karim benzema a été
élu hier soir meilleur joueur de ligue 1
par ses pairs et à 20 ans seulement
hatem ben arfa était désignée révélation
de l'année
entraîneur de l'année laurent blanc aux
girondins de bordeaux avant de refermer
cette édition je vous en rappelle l'un
des principaux titres un puissant
tremblement de terre a fait au moins
huit mille 700 morts dans le sud de la
chine le bilan pourrait être beaucoup
plus lourd car des milliers d'immeubles
des universités des lycées deux usines
chimiques également se sont effondrées
sur leurs occupants l'armée nationale et
mobiliser le premier ministre chinois
s'est rendu sur place les autorités
semblent vouloir faire preuve de la plus
grande transparence
george bush a officiellement proposé
tout à l'heure l'aide des états unis
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
tania young
20h50 fbi portés disparus 23h10 vous
avez rendez vous avec complément d
enquête autour de benoît duquesne le
grand désordre alimentaire à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr
et